and really close everybody
Tia and Tamira Mowry reunite at The
Little Mermaid Premiere with their
daughters in tow we definitely
prioritize our time together I'm a True
Believer in just creating memories you
know what I mean memories with family
it's it means everything to us on Monday
the twins shared a rare family night in
LA with their daughters Cairo and Araya
posing together on the blue carpet and
tia she posted some behind the scenes
Clips on Instagram
[Music]
Tamara now lives in Napa your full-time
living in Napa working on your your
Vineyard and this amazing family that
you've created what is life like for you
now in this next chapter
there's one word I can think of and it's
peace I have peace because I'm with my
family and my family rejuvenates me it
is seriously a dream so the sweet sister
moment was extra special but Tia and
Tamira weren't the only celebs to bring
their kiddos offset and his daughter's
culture and Kalia dressed to impress in
coordinating black and white ensembles
Kenya Moore stepped out with her
four-year-old daughter Brooklyn and
Melissa McCarthy who plays Ursula in the
flick posed with her 13 year old
daughter Georgette and hubby Ben falcomm
the two also share a 16 year old
daughter Vivian I have my girls with me
and they each brought a friend they're
already like we'll just go in and get
popcorn as for Tia she had an extra
meaningful reason why she and Cairo were
excited to see a new take on the Disney
classic this is so special to us because
it's all about representation right you
get to see a little mermaid that looks
like you and it's very nostalgic for me
too you guys because I grew up watching
this movie so to be able to see it with
Cairo is just a dream come true of
course Ariel is played by Halle Bailey
in the live action adaptation of the
Disney film
[Music]
something's starting right now
it feels absolutely amazing to
officially be a Disney princess I mean I
think that it's something that we have
all just had in our dreams I just am
really grateful to be in this position
when ET chatted with the actress just
hours before the premiere she explained
how she feels knowing little girls are
inspired seeing her on the big screen
it's been such a beautiful moment for me
to be able to see the reactions of the
babies it makes me just emotionally
overwhelmed honestly and I cry as soon
as I watch them because I think of the
little girl that's still in me honestly
and it heals that girl inside of me and
to watch them feel like they have
representation and someone to look to to
know that they deserve to be in those
spaces too is so important so yeah it
just makes me cry anytime I see any of
those videos and Hallie's big sis Chloe
couldn't be more proud I've been trying
to not cry every time I think about it
well you're gonna cry you're gonna cry I
gotta get tissues with me I'm so
freaking proud of her I've been seeing
Billboards and magazines of her
everywhere and I am just so freaking
proud and we get to be here now and I'm
just so proud of her for believing in
herself and finding her inner strength
and taking on such an iconic role and
being so phenomenal at it
[Music]
thank you